hey lieben da draußen
300.000 abonnenten ich kann es gar nicht
glauben und ohne euch wäre das alles
nicht möglich gewesen
ja das ist schon echt lang er zwei jahre
läuft unser kanal und der floh nicht
einmal gedacht für human ganz alten
schinken aus einer schublade
vor acht jahren mein erster tv-auftritt
mann war ich noch jung viel spaß damit
da war ich ja doch noch frischfleisch in
der tv szene die allermeisten hersteller
von fertiggerichten wollen nicht auf
zusatzstoffe verzichten mit welchen
tricks dabei gearbeitet wird müssen nur
wenige insider wir sind mit sebastian
liege verabredet der 34-jährige ist
produktentwickler für fertiggerichte
wirkstoffe sind wie schädlich aber um so
mehr e nummern drinne sind natürlich
umso minderwertiger auch das
grundprodukt festgesetzt
sebastian lege zeigt uns wie man mit
zusatzstoffen sogenannten formschinken
zaubern kann den belag von millionen
tiefkühlpizza dieser formschinken
besteht nicht aus echtem schinken
sondern aus fleischresten vom
schlachthof
fleisch fleisch abschnitte
kleine würfel des fleisch abschnitt
fleisch wie lasst das wieder
zusammenwachsen zu einem stück
man nehme den zusatzstoff trans glutamin
ase ein enzym das wie ein kleber wirkt
passieren wir mal die luft hier raus und
muss dementsprechend spannend stark
aneinander zu pressen um eine ideale
verklebung nachher zu erziehen jetzt
muss das ganze nur noch in 60 grad warme
wasser wahrt damit er fleich kleber
seine volle wirkung entfalten kann nach
einer stunde ist das fleisch gar und die
einzelnen stücke sind fest miteinander
verbunden
und wir denken
die ersten ein komplettes stück
aber in wahrheit ist es klebefleisch
hergestellt aus billigen resten sagen
wir die normale frischetheke graf solche
sachen nicht zurück das wird dann eher
für convenience produkte pizza werden
solche sachen
das deutsche lebensmittelrecht lässt die
bezeichnung schinken für das
klebefleisch ausdrücklich zu solange nur
der hinweis form genannt wird deshalb
also formschinken aber nochmals
vielen dank dass wir unsere support so
geile
kommentare schreibt immer wieder dabei
sein mir auch so liebe nachrichten
hinterlassen ich danke euch von ganzem
herzen das ist wirklich mega
und wir werden uns weiter genau so viel
mühe geben euch so zu unterhalten
bis dann tschüss